肯定是对这个男的也还是挺满意的，
对他父母的做法也是可以接受的，
现在就是说这个事儿能瞒多久，
最终是谁来接这个锅，
接了这个锅将面临的后续的这些矛盾和麻烦，
你能不能承受？
假设我是说假设揭开了这个锅了，
人家父母死活不同意以死相逼，
他能顶得住吗？
你认为我在上一段婚姻的话，
有一个女儿，
现在的话是6岁，
而且男方再也没有抚养费，
因为现在他们家那边的话是拆迁了，
所以说搬家了也失联，
中间也不让看，
因为当时落的也比较僵。
有一个男朋友认识两年了，
谈了有一年半，
我现在的话是那个33岁，
他是独生子，
年龄比我小了5岁，
他的工作岗位的话是消瘦，
平均收入的话是在7K，
他的优点的话就是性格比较温和，
心思也比较单纯，
也是属于愿意付出的的一种，
情绪比较稳定，
因为原生家庭比较好，
对于我们自己来说的话是没有拖累，
而且还能帮忙。
他的缺点的话就是属于话少，
语言沟通能力比较弱，
事业心的话也是一般，
嗯，
但是人比较勤奋，
而且人情世故都蛮好，
因为人比较单纯嘛，
但是他也愿意听，
他觉得你讲得有道理，
他是属于很愿意去学习的这一种，
嗯，
他自己的家庭的话是这样的，
他的父母的话都是属于有工作的，
而且母亲也已经退休了，
然后自己家里的话是属于有车有房没有。
贷款的这种婚后的话，
我们是跟父母不一起住，
但是我们都在一个城市，
包括跟我前面的那一家的话，
也是属于在一个城市里边生活的，
我我们都是属于在二线城市，
我自己的原生家庭的话，
就是我爸爸走的早，
然后家里面境的话就是我母亲，
我母亲的话是跟我弟弟一起生活，
我们老家是就是我从小到大生长环境的话是农村的，
我弟弟现在结婚了，
我自己的原生家庭的话，
基于我以后的生活来说是给不了任何帮助的，
但是她也不拖累，
我们自己有一套这个小房子，
总价的话大概是在就是60个W左右，
我每个月平均的收入是一个W，
然后身上的话大概有一个几万块钱的存款，
我们的话啊，
现在谈了有一年半，
认识有两年了，
但是他父母不知道我上一段婚姻有个女儿，
因为他不打算给父母讲，
嗯，
之前我不是有一段那个婚史嘛，
然后呢，
也是我逼着让他说的，
因为我担心这个事情万一婚后知道的话，
对我们都不好，
但是的话，
他不打算给父母说那个有女儿的这个事情，
但是我自己的话，
我觉得我有点说不出口，
我刚开始的时候肯定是觉得她年龄小，
跟我不太合适，
不太合适的话有两点，
第一点的话是因为我有过一个婚姻，
而且有个女儿，
我自己的原生家庭你没有他的原生家庭好，
再加上呢，
我觉得年龄小的人，
对于我这种离过婚的，
我现里面没有谱，
我觉得年龄小的人可能他考虑的没有那么长远，
而且的话，
我害怕第二次又把我耽误了，
就是不再婚，
我都不想着就是再出现这样的事情。
因为我的。
想还是比较传统，
就是我说我一个女儿有不到婚姻，
所以我们不合适，
这样的年龄小，
精历少，
但是他说她不在乎，
但是我说完以后的话，
她比之前追我的时候的话更愿意付出，
而且还就是更正诚一些了，
我就考虑了，
然后考虑完以后的话，
我是这么给他说的，
我说那你就跟你父母说一下，
你跟你是父母，
就是把我跟你说的这些东西，
你咱们都给他们说完，
父母如果不介意了，
咱们就相处了，
是一下，
他当时跟我说的是他给他父母说过了，
所以我们两个才选择相处的，
结果他相处到今年的5月份的时候，
就相处了一年，
我他父母提出来要去一趟我老家，
意思就是其实年龄也差不多了嘛，
意思去一趟我我老家见一下我的一个家里人，
然后把两个娃的事情，
正式的父母之间的话说开，
然后那个时候我问他的时候，
他才说他给他父母没有说，
我说如果你跟你父母不讲的话，
那我们这个事情就没有办法再进一步了，
因为现在已经开始了一年多了，
如果说直接现在现在就说分开的话，
确实也是属于有感情的，
再加上我们相处的这一年多的话，
我们之前也没有发生过任何多的一些矛盾呀什么之类的，
我们的性格也是属于互补的那一种类型，
他就给他父母只说了有一段婚史，
没有说这个女儿的事情，
我记得他当时是早上说的，
是发微信的时候就是把原委都说清楚了，
意思于人家让我给你说的是我自己没有跟你说，
但是我觉得这个事情还要往前推进呢，
那我就给你们父母意思是说一下，
然后呢，
他就是有这个事情，
他的父母就问他有没有娃，
他说没有，
我当时也没有说是强制性的，
说是你必须得要跟你父母说，
如果没有强制性的。
说的话就说明一个问题，
就说明我我有点默认了，
因为我确实打，
就是心里面当时想还是想跟他相处的，
但是我当时就跟他父母吃了个饭，
那就是5月份的时候，
也就是谈了一年左右的时候，
我说叔叔阿姨呢，
我们就是这样子的，
才给你说完我之前之前的这个事情嘛，
现在回老家的话，
我说时间不是很合适，
我说第一的话啊，
因为你们才刚知道，
给家里人说的也就是能接受的了，
包括给儿子说的也是能接受的，
跟我说的意思是也能行，
但是我觉得你们刚知道的话，
你们自己的话就是消化一下，
再加上的话，
我跟他的话还是要再磨合一下，
如果磨合的好的话啊，
我们后半年的时候就是在说去家里的事儿，
前三天的时候，
他姆之前就是九月份也说过，
意思就是我爸妈要去你家里，
我们要说一下这个事情，
今年就是过完年以后的话，
想把这个婚事往上提一下呢，
哎，
我想着我大概也33岁了，
其实后期还也是要考虑家庭的，
但是对于我来说的话，
也是属于当下比较好的一个选择，
但是去了以后的话，
一切谈的也都挺顺利的，
就去我们老家以后谈的也都挺顺利的，
就我现在担心的问题就是啥呢？
就是他父母现在不知道我有个女儿，
我害怕的是万一知道了以后的话，
可能会引起家里面的一个家庭大矛盾，
我就害怕，
哎，
反正我现在心里面，
我就是我比较惶恐你的这个对象，
这个本人，
他是一个独立性很强的人格吗？
不是，
他如果不是一个独立性很强的人格的话，
这日子没法往下过。
你去看一个电影，
这个电影叫冯琦的忏悔。
就如果这个男的，
他没有到一种很强大的独立的灵魂的时候的话，
这日子很难往下过。
冯琪的忏悔，
他讲的大概就是一个离过婚，
有过一个小孩儿，
到一个女性在火车上认识了一个当兵的，
这当兵的比他也小几岁，
刚开始的时候可热烈了，
为了你，
我什么都行，
为了你怎么怎么样，
后来就回到老家的时候，
就是让他父母知道了这个女的离过婚，
有一个女儿，
然后父母死活都不同意，
包括他那个单位上的那些领导也不同意啊什么的，
后来他最终还是放弃了。
如果你的这个对象，
他本人是一个很独立的灵魂，
那无所谓，
他可以对抗全世界，
他可以为了他自己对抗全世界，
如果他本人不是一个很独立的灵魂，
他还得靠着爸妈给他攒彩礼钱，
靠着爸妈给他买房子啊什么的，
那矛盾是不可避免的，
就是这日子很难过得好，
对于这个彩礼跟这个买房子的这个事情上面的话，
我们就没有，
因为我们没有争议，
首先的话就是因为离得比较远嘛，
我们跨省嘛，
他父母也谈到这个事情了，
那父母当时是说的是就是给了6.6的一个W的现金给我，
就是当时去的时候人家就拿着，
然后完了以后的话，
又给了一个10个W的一个卡，
这个我们家没有要，
人家就直接给的，
意思是这个的话，
因为你们可以装房子啊用呀什么之类的，
这个的话就直接给你们家的现金，
我妈在这边的话，
就是日子是两个娃做的，
我们家里面也。
不要，
也就是要了以后的话，
也就是给咱们给这两个娃，
反正大家也就是希望他们把日子过好，
所以当下的话就是这么说呢，
所以这个东西的话，
现在的话就是还是给在我的手里的，
我自己拿着，
因为不存在于房子的问题的原因是啥？
就是他们是属于这个市里面的本地人，
他们本身自己就有房子，
就是那种老房子，
想别的都没有多大的意义，
我也知道你，
你肯定是对这个男的也是挺满意的，
对他父母的做法也是可以接受的，
现在就是说这个事儿能瞒多久，
最终是谁来接这个锅，
揭了这个锅将面临的后续的这些矛盾和麻烦，
你能不能承受，
假设，
我是说假设揭开了这个锅了，
人家父母死活不同意以死相逼，
他能顶得住吗？
你认为应该顶不住啊，
那早晚是要揭开这个锅的，
当然也有一种可能性是什么呢？
生米煮成熟饭，
你这个孩子都2岁了，
然后他才发现，
哦，
你原来还生过一个孩子，
那没办法，
能瞒到那会儿吗？
我估计这很难吧，
很难瞒到那会儿，
与其说战战兢兢的怎么怎么地的啊，
暴风雨还不如提前来，
来了之后就归于平静，
是不是趁着现在让他直接现在去给他父母说，
直接就说明白，
能行的话就是我们就接下来的话就往下走一步，
如果不能行的话，
我们就把这个事情就直接现在就该退了这样一个，
要不然这日子过起来多糟心，
你说这日子过起来多糟。
亲，
你爸妈还得帮着你瞒亲戚朋友还得都打招呼，
哎，
关键是孩子多多苦啊，
孩子想来看你的话，
你还得躲着，
还不让孩子看你这些日子过得多操心。
我感觉生活这个事情就是一旦有了一个谎言，
你要用100个1000个谎言来圆这个谎言，
关键是你得逼着你爸妈都跟你演戏，
亲戚朋友都得跟你演戏，
周围的邻居都得跟你演戏，
孩子还不能来找你。
嗯，
就是首先啊，
姐妹啊，
我要从配得感上过我自己心里这一关，
那只是我合法的生了一个孩子，
我又没有偷人，
我又没有破坏别人的家庭，
我没有任何道德上的问题，
对不对？
而且我不认为我生了一个孩子就觉得我低人一等，
我生了一个孩子，
正好证明我生育能力没问题，
正好证明我身体健康，
首先从我自己这心理这一关的话，
我要过得去，
如果说你的爸妈不同意，
你接受不了的话，
那是你的问题，
不是我的问题，
嗯，
我理解了对不对？
我不认为说女人生了一个孩子是我的一个黑点吗？
是我一个污点吗？
不是，
她还证明我确实生育功能没毛病，
我身体健康，
嗯，
我又不是偷人，
我又不是给别人做小三，
我又不是破坏别人家庭，
我要搞个私生子，
我合理合法的生个孩子，
我怕什么？
只有当你自己心里是这样的时候，
你才能够对抗一切，
才能够应对一切，
那如果说他不愿意说的话，
我让我父母打电话给他，
父母直接讲清楚的话，
这样能行吗？
能行啊，
我自己直说也。
能行吗？
嗯，
我的第一段婚姻的情况下的话，
他们那边不是拆迁的嘛，
当年就是也有我的一份，
明年可能房子都会下来，
房子这个地方的话有点争议，
一个人的话是65㎡，
还是按照人头分的，
但是他们要的就是当时找的人要的那个面积的话，
是两个95的，
两个135的，
那我该争取我的那一份吗？
还是就是说你的户口还在前夫家，
所以你们现在出来了以后的话，
人家就已经那边所户了，
按照法律来说，
该分的法律来说是该分给我这种法院都有那个确认面积的那个确认书，
我觉得这事儿就吧，
按照法律来说该给我的话，
那我为啥不争取呢？
我可以争取来了之后，
甚至于我可以给孩子存着也行啊，
我为啥不争取啊，
我给孩子不行啊，
我争取来了之后，
我要放到孩子名下也行啊，
啊，
折成钱呗，
好，
拜拜，
刚刚刚有个朋友说离了婚是不是就没有了，
那得看他什么时候锁的户口，
什么时候锁的政策，
什么时候办的那个拆迁的程序，
你知道吧，
就只要说这拆迁程序已经完成了啊，
就得给你们家多少，
因为你们家有多了一个口，
人多了一个户口，
多少多少平米好锁完了他俩再离，
不影响啊是不是？
那这事儿就看先后顺序喽，
就看该是啥是啥喽，
我感觉是这样子的啊，
所有的姐妹们啊，
我以前经常看那种电视剧，
比如说要分遗产的时候，
总有那种高风亮节的上来就说我不要总有这种的是不是？
其实我心想这事不应该这么干。
这事应该分到我手里的时候，
我看谁对我好，
我给他点，
分到我手里的时候，
我看谁困难，
我给他点，
那是情分，
那我上来就说我放弃了，
这算怎么回事呀？
谁也不领我的情，
就我这小气啊是吧？
我放弃我的利益，
你总得领我的情吧？
记得点赞关注哦。